This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When Harry Reeves was in middle school, he cared what his classmates thought of him. Now, all middle schoolers want to fit in with their peers. But Harry, he was next level. I was somewhat insecure as an adolescent, very unsure of my standing within the social group that I lived in and I would keep daily charts of how I was doing and who I connected with and who I did not connect with.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。哈里·里斯上初中时，很在意同学对他的看法。现在，所有的初中生都想融入同龄人。但哈里，他达到了另一个境界。我青春期时有点缺乏安全感，对自己在我所处的社交群体中的地位非常不确定，我会每天记录自己的表现，以及我和谁建立了联系，和谁没有建立联系。
Harry's charts did more than track who sat next to him at lunch or who joked around with him in the hallway. No this is actually more embarrassing than that. These were actually graphs where I would rate on a 10 point scale how I had done with various people on that day. So if I thought that a certain person had really liked me on that day, you know, they would get a nine. And if I thought I'd really come across as an idiot with another person
哈里的图表记录的内容不仅仅是谁在午餐时坐在他旁边，或者谁在走廊里和他开玩笑。不，这实际上比那更令人尴尬。这些实际上是图表，我会用10分制来评价我那天与不同人的相处情况。所以，如果我觉得某个人那天真的很喜欢我，你知道，他们会得到九分。如果我觉得我在另一个人面前表现得像个白痴
that might be a two or three And I would have these charts over time where the lines would go up and down It was a painful way to go through middle school But it did come with an upside Years later Harry learned there were people who kept such charts Professionally, I discovered oh my god. They're people who actually make a life of studying this stuff. And it just instantly grabbed me because it was something that I had always been doing. Harry went on to become a social psychologist, and he discovered that if you keep meticulous
那可能就是两分或三分。随着时间的推移，我会有这些图表，线条会上下波动。这是一种度过初中生活的痛苦方式，但它确实有一个好处。多年后，哈里了解到还有其他人也保留着这样的图表。在职业上，我发现，天哪，真的有人以研究这些东西为生。它立刻吸引了我，因为这是我一直以来都在做的事情。哈里后来成为了一名社会心理学家，他发现如果你做细致的
charts, if you track the ups and downs of relationships like an insecure middle schooler, you can actually discover really interesting things about the air-bend flow of human relationships. This week on Hidden Brain, the secret ingredient that makes some relationships thrive and others falter. Many of us know what it's like to meet a soulmate or kindred spirit at work. We know what it feels like to be inspired by a politician or a business leader. But what exactly prompts us to feel this deep connection with some people, but not with others? Is it having a shared goal, the intangibles of chemistry? exactly prompts us to feel this deep connection with some people, but not with others. Is it having a shared goal, the intangibles of chemistry, or does it have to do with temperament and personality?
图表，如果你像一个缺乏安全感的初中生一样追踪人际关系的起伏，你实际上可以发现关于人际关系流动的一些非常有趣的事情。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨让一些关系蓬勃发展而另一些关系失败的秘诀。我们许多人都知道在工作中遇到灵魂伴侣或志同道合的人是什么感觉。我们知道被政治家或商业领袖激励是什么感觉。但究竟是什么促使我们与某些人产生这种深层联系，而与其他人却没有呢？是因为有共同的目标，还是化学反应的无形因素？究竟是什么促使我们与某些人产生这种深层联系，而与其他人却没有呢？是因为有共同的目标，还是化学反应的无形因素，还是与气质和个性有关？
It turns out that beneath the feeling of being close to someone is a powerful psychological mechanism. At the University of Rochester, psychologist Harry Reese has studied this core ingredient of successful relationships. Harry Reese, welcome to Hidden Bray. Glad to be here. I want to start by spending some time talking about a relationship in your own life, Harry. I think it speaks to some of the research insights you've developed over the years.
事实证明，在与某人亲近的感觉之下，是一种强大的心理机制。在罗切斯特大学，心理学家哈里·里斯研究了成功人际关系的核心要素。哈里·里斯，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴来到这里。我想先花点时间谈谈你生活中的一段关系，哈里。我认为这说明了你多年来发展出的一些研究见解。
I understand you grew up in a very tight-knit community. You got married very young to a woman who was also from that same community. What was that relationship like when you first got married? You know, we grew up in a German Jewish community in the upper parts of Manhattan. And the community was very insular, it was very warm and connected, but there was also a sense that you would stay in that community when you got older, when you got married, and began to raise children on your own. And so I had the expectation that I would find a partner in that group, and in fact I did.
据我了解，你在一个非常紧密的社区中长大。你很年轻就娶了一位同样来自那个社区的女性。你们刚结婚时那段关系是什么样的？你知道，我们在曼哈顿上城的一个德裔犹太社区长大。这个社区非常封闭，非常温暖和紧密，但也有这样一种观念，即当你长大、结婚并开始自己抚养孩子时，你会留在那个社区。所以我期望在那个群体中找到一个伴侣，事实上我也确实找到了。
I met my first wife when I was 19. She came from the same social community that I came from, and we started dating largely because it was expected that you would start dating at that age. All of my friends were doing it, all of my cousins were doing it, and so I did it. And at the age of 21, we decided to get married. It was literally the exact day I graduated from college. Wow. That was the age in which all of our parents had gotten married. And you know, in the old country. So that was what was expected.
我19岁时遇到了我的第一任妻子。她来自和我同一个社交圈，我们开始约会主要是因为当时到了那个年龄就应该开始约会。我所有的朋友都在这样做，我所有的表兄弟姐妹都在这样做，所以我也做了。21岁时，我们决定结婚。那简直就是我大学毕业的那一天。哇。那是我们所有父母结婚的年龄。你知道，在老家。所以这就是人们所期望的。
At a certain point in your early adulthood, I think this was around the time you were in graduate school, you got involved in what were known at the time as encounter groups or encounter sessions. For people who aren't familiar with that term today, can you describe what they were, Harry? Yes, encounter groups were very popular in the late 1960s and 1970s. They were laboratories in which people could be completely open and honest, talk about what they authentically felt, what their goals and needs were, and get honest feedback from other people
在你成年早期，我想大约是在你读研究生的时候，你参与了当时所谓的“遭遇小组”或“遭遇会议”。对于今天不熟悉这个术语的人，你能描述一下它们是什么吗，哈里？是的，遭遇小组在20世纪60年代末和70年代非常流行。它们是实验室，人们可以在其中完全开放和诚实，谈论他们真实的感觉、他们的目标和需求，并从其他人那里获得诚实的反馈
about how they were coming across to them, because there's so much of our natural social interaction that involves being polite, not really talking about what you're thinking and feeling and the ground rules of these encounter groups were to be open and honest in everything that you said and did. And did you say things in this group that you hadn't said before? Did you reveal parts of yourself that you hadn't revealed to other people
关于他们给别人留下的印象，因为我们自然的社交互动中有很多涉及礼貌，而不是真正谈论你在想什么和感觉什么，而这些遭遇小组的基本规则是，在你所说和所做的一切中都要开放和诚实。你在小组里说了以前没说过的话吗？你是否揭示了你以前没有向其他人揭示过的自己的一部分
in your family growing up, what your wife? Yes, I began to talk about how I saw my life, how I saw the community I came from, but also where I wanted to go with my life, what I wanted to accomplish professionally, but also personally. And because I was in graduate school at NYU at the time, which was in Greenwich Village,
在你成长的家庭中，或者你的妻子？是的，我开始谈论我是如何看待我的生活的，我是如何看待我出身的社区的，但也谈论我想在生活中去向何方，我想在职业上以及个人生活中实现什么。因为我当时在纽约大学读研究生，就在格林威治村，
which of course was a very lively, contemporary culture at the time, which was in Greenwich Village, which of course was a very lively, contemporary culture at the time, and was beginning to experience the idea that the world I grew up in was not the world that I wanted to live my life in, but this was not something that I felt that I could talk about with my family or for that matter with my wife, and I began to talk about it in the context of the group and literally was blown away by the feedback that I got from other people. So you were having these sessions in these encounter groups and learning perhaps parts of yourself, learning things about yourself that you hadn't known before.
那当然是一个非常活跃、现代的文化，当时我开始体验到我成长的世界并不是我想生活在其中的世界，但这并不是我觉得可以和家人或妻子谈论的事情，我开始在小组的背景下谈论它，并被我从其他人那里得到的反馈彻底震撼了。所以你在这些遭遇小组中进行这些会议，也许了解了自己的一部分，了解了以前不知道的关于自己的事情。
Were you able to bring this back to your marriage? Were you able to talk with your wife about what was going on? Did you have conversations about it? And I'm wondering if so, what they were like? Well, that was the problem. When I would begin to talk about these things, there was no recognition by my wife at all about what I was talking about. This was very contrary to what she knew about,
你能够把这些带回你的婚姻吗？你能够和你的妻子谈论正在发生的事情吗？你们对此进行过对话吗？我想知道如果是这样，它们是什么样的？嗯，这就是问题所在。当我开始谈论这些事情时，我的妻子根本无法理解我在说什么。这与她所知道的、
what she had experienced and there was just no connection there at all. And so our relationship really became a very distant relationship. It was not hostile. She was not mean about it in any way. She simply couldn't connect with it. And in a very real sense sense I was moving in a different direction and that was a direction that she couldn't come along.
她所经历的非常相反，根本没有任何联系。所以我们的关系真的变成了一种非常疏远的关系。它并不敌对。她并没有以任何方式表现得刻薄。她只是无法与之产生共鸣。在非常真实的意义上，我正在朝着不同的方向前进，而那是她无法跟随的方向。
So there's obviously some tension here between the kind of person you were, the encounter groups, you felt like in some ways this was the authentic Harry, in some ways you couldn't be that authentic person in your marriage. What effect did this have on your marriage, Harry? in some ways you couldn't be that authentic person in your marriage. What effect did this have on your marriage, Harry? Well, it basically ended it. Of course, it took a year or a year and a half for that to actually happen. But essentially, I began to experience my outside life as far more rewarding and far more meaningful than the life that I had with my wife.
所以这里显然存在一些紧张关系，关于你是什么样的人，遭遇小组，你觉得在某种程度上这是真实的哈里，在某种程度上你无法在婚姻中成为那个真实的人。这对你的婚姻有什么影响，哈里？在某种程度上你无法在婚姻中成为那个真实的人。这对你的婚姻有什么影响，哈里？嗯，它基本上结束了这段婚姻。当然，这花了一年或一年半的时间才真正发生。但本质上，我开始觉得我的外部生活比我和妻子在一起的生活更有回报、更有意义。
And so we began to spend less time together, our time together would be more structure on formalities rather than the kind of intimacies that should go on in a marriage. The story that you're telling about your marriage is I think really revealing because it also matches what your research has been finding over the last several years. What is the relationship between the experience of being understood in an intimate relationship and
所以我们开始减少在一起的时间，我们在一起的时间更多地建立在形式上，而不是婚姻中应该有的那种亲密关系。你讲述的关于你婚姻的故事，我认为非常具有启发性，因为它也符合你过去几年研究发现的结果。在亲密关系中被理解的体验与
the likelihood of success or failure of that relationship? Understanding is one of the most important things that we want in our close relationships. This is actually true beyond the realm of close relationships, but especially in our most intimate relationships, our marriages, our friendships, our connections with our siblings and the rest of our family, one of the most powerful things that we want is for there to be real understanding in those relationships that the people on the other side know who we are and are caring and validating and accepting of that person. It's interesting, I think, when most people think of intimate relationships, they think
该关系成功或失败的可能性之间有什么关系？理解是我们希望在亲密关系中得到的最重要的事情之一。这实际上不仅适用于亲密关系领域，而且特别是在我们最亲密的关系中，我们的婚姻、友谊、与兄弟姐妹以及其他家人的联系，我们想要的最强大的东西之一就是这些关系中存在真正的理解，即对方知道我们是谁，并且关心、认可和接受那个人。有趣的是，我认为当大多数人想到亲密关系时，他们会想到
about things like love or appreciation or stability, but of course, the moment you say this, it makes intuitive sense to me that one thing to be understood is absolutely core to intimate relationships. Well, I think the important point is that things like love and trust and caring simply don't work if there isn't understanding. If your understanding of me is different than how I understand myself, then when you tell me how much you love me, you're telling me that you love somebody different than me. And if I tell you how much I appreciate you, but in fact, I'm appreciating you for the things that you're not, you don't think are
爱、欣赏或稳定之类的事情，但当然，当你这么说时，我直觉地感到，被理解绝对是亲密关系的核心。嗯，我认为重点是，像爱、信任和关心这样的事情，如果没有理解，根本行不通。如果你对我的理解与我对自己的理解不同，那么当你告诉我你有多爱我时，你是在告诉我你爱的是一个与我不同的人。如果我告诉你我有多欣赏你，但事实上，我欣赏你是因为你不是的那些事情，你并不认为
the most important things about yourself. Some of my feedback will now start to sound inauthentic to you. And in fact, we have done research where we did exactly that. And a very interesting thing happens. People smile, they say they're happy to get the feedback, and then they want to get out of there as fast as possible in case the other person finds out how false the impression was. So it feels inauthentic and very unrewarding. It will suppose you got a nice big raise at work from your boss and they said they're
那是关于你自己最重要的事情。我的一些反馈现在听起来对你来说就不真实了。事实上，我们确实做了完全那样的研究。一件非常有趣的事情发生了。人们微笑着，说他们很高兴得到反馈，然后他们想尽快离开那里，以防对方发现这个印象是多么虚假。所以它感觉不真实且非常没有回报。假设你在工作中从老板那里得到了很好的加薪，他们说他们
giving you the raise because of something that isn't true about you. You know, think about how uncomfortable that would feel. Yeah, it makes you feel like an imposter almost. Exactly. The moment I heard about Harry's work, I started to see its applications everywhere. Think about the perennial conflict between parents and children. So much of it can be traced to the feeling many kids have that their parents just don't get them. Take the opening scene of the movie, Lady Bird, a teenager and her mom are driving back from
给你加薪是因为一些关于你不真实的事情。你知道，想想那会感觉多么不舒服。是的，这让你感觉几乎像个冒名顶替者。完全正确。我一听到哈里的工作，就开始到处看到它的应用。想想父母和孩子之间永恒的冲突。其中很多可以追溯到许多孩子觉得他们的父母根本不了解他们的感觉。看看电影《伯德小姐》的开场场景，一个十几岁的女孩和她的妈妈从
a college tour and they start to squabble. I wish I could live through something. Aren't you? Nope. The only exciting thing about 2002 is that it's a palindrome. Okay fine. Well yours is the worst life of all so you win. Oh so now you're mad.
大学参观回来，他们开始争吵。我希望我能经历点什么。你不是吗？没有。2002年唯一令人兴奋的事情是它是一个回文。好吧，好吧。好吧，你的生活是最糟糕的，所以你赢了。哦，所以现在你生气了。
No, because I wanted to listen because you have a great I'm sorry. I'm not perfect. No one's asking you to be perfect. Just consider it would do I don't even want to go to school in this state anyway. I hate California Obviously, this is a comedy But the teenagers fury at being misunderstood is palpable. I want to go where culture is like you are I raised a child at least Connecticut or New Hampshire where writers live in the woods. Get into those schools anyway. Mom can't even pass your driver's test.
不，因为我想听，因为你有一个很棒的……我很抱歉。我不完美。没人要求你完美。只是考虑一下……我甚至不想在这个州上学。我讨厌加州。显然，这是一部喜剧。但青少年因被误解而产生的愤怒是显而易见的。我想去文化像你一样的地方。我至少抚养了一个孩子，康涅狄格州或新罕布什尔州，作家住在树林里。无论如何都要进入那些学校。妈妈甚至不能通过你的驾照考试。
It's a very common feeling for adolescents and for that matter adults to feel like their parents don't understand them. And sometimes that comes from the fact that, you know, we grow, we change. Often we move away from our families and become things that our families don't necessarily have an appreciation of. I want to talk a little bit about the implications of your work, not in the context of intimate relationships, but in the context of professional relationships. You said a second ago that wanting to be understood is core to intimate relationships,
对于青少年以及成年人来说，感觉父母不了解他们是一种非常普遍的感觉。有时这源于这样一个事实，你知道，我们成长，我们改变。我们经常远离我们的家庭，成为我们的家庭不一定欣赏的东西。我想谈谈你的工作的影响，不是在亲密关系的背景下，而是在职业关系的背景下。你刚才说，想要被理解是亲密关系的核心，
but I have the sense that it also plays a role in professional relationships. Can you talk about that? Can you talk about the importance, for example, as an academic for your fellow peers, not just to think that you're a good research or a smart person, but to truly understand the insights that you have developed over the years?
但我感觉它在职业关系中也起着作用。你能谈谈那个吗？你能谈谈重要性吗，例如，作为一名学者，对于你的同行来说，不仅仅是认为你是一个好的研究者或聪明的人，而是真正理解你多年来发展出的见解？
Well, sure, in the academy, it's very important that our colleagues, the people who are working with toward the common goal of doing research and educating students and each other, it's very important that they understand what we're trying to do in our work, that they get the message, not only the superficial content of it, but also the meta messageessage that is underneath
嗯，当然，在学术界，我们的同事，那些为了研究和教育学生以及彼此的共同目标而一起工作的人，非常重要的一点是，他们理解我们在工作中试图做什么，他们领会了信息，不仅是表面的内容，还有底层的元信息
that. It's true in medicine when there's much research that shows that medical care works better when patients feel like their doctors are listening and really understand what their symptoms are, what their needs are, what they want done. It's common in the classroom also. Students do better when they feel like their teachers understand who they are and what their priorities are. It may be helpful to think about what happens when we don't receive that kind of understanding
那。在医学中也是如此，有许多研究表明，当患者觉得他们的医生在倾听并真正理解他们的症状、他们的需求、他们想要做什么时，医疗护理效果更好。在课堂上也一样。当学生觉得他们的老师了解他们是谁以及他们的优先事项是什么时，他们表现得更好。思考当我们没有得到那种理解时会发生什么可能会有帮助
in professional settings. Students who think that professors don't understand them are more likely to end up feeling lackadaisical about their studies. A patient who thinks her doctor can't be bothered to listen to her might disregard otherwise excellent medical guidance. Over time, if we feel our colleagues and clients and customers don't understand what we go through every day, we become much more likely to snap. That's what happened to JetBlue Flight Attendant, Steven Slater.
在职业环境中。认为教授不了解他们的学生更有可能最终对学习感到懒散。认为她的医生懒得听她说话的病人可能会忽视本来很棒的医疗指导。随着时间的推移，如果我们觉得我们的同事、客户和顾客不了解我们每天经历的事情，我们变得更有可能崩溃。这就是捷蓝航空空乘史蒂文·斯莱特发生的事情。
Like many flight attendants, he had trouble getting passengers to sit down while the plane was still taxing. As he argued with one woman, a piece of luggage got loose and hit him in the head. Here's what happened next, according to a Boston TV station. That's when witnesses say Slater lost it, telling off the entire plane cursing at passengers from the intercom. His profanity lace tie-rate ended with a quote, I've been in this business for 28 years. I've had it. That's it. Slater swung open the plane's side door and rode the evacuation
像许多空乘人员一样，他在飞机还在滑行时让乘客坐下遇到了麻烦。当他和一名妇女争吵时，一件行李松脱并击中了他的头部。据波士顿一家电视台报道，接下来发生了什么。就在那时，目击者说斯莱特崩溃了，通过对讲机咒骂乘客，斥责整个飞机。他充满脏话的咆哮以一句“我在这行干了28年了。我受够了。就是这样”结束。斯莱特猛地打开飞机的侧门，骑着疏散
shoot down to the tarmac. I asked Harry to talk about how a lack of understanding from colleagues and customers can produce burnout. People feeling misunderstood is something that is growing by leaps and bounds in the world we live in now. With all the stresses and tensions that we have, there's more and more of a need to get connected with other people and part of that connection involves the sense of really understanding where people are coming from. In the old world, you know, most of the people that you dealt with were people from your community.
滑梯滑到了停机坪上。我请哈里谈谈同事和客户缺乏理解如何导致倦怠。人们感到被误解是我们现在生活的世界中正在飞速增长的事情。随着我们所有的压力和紧张，越来越需要与其他人建立联系，而这种联系的一部分涉及真正理解人们来自哪里的感觉。在旧世界，你知道，你打交道的大多数人都是来自你社区的人。
People who had lives that were relatively similar to yours who lived with the same context as you lived with. And it was easy enough to understand them because everything that they were facing was the same as what you were facing. But now we're so much more mobile and we're so much more connected, we're coming across people who have different backgrounds, different goals, different priorities, indeed they may be living on opposite sides of the planet. And so the context is so much different and it's so much harder to establish that core base of understanding. Why do you think it is that being understood is so important to human beings Harry. What is happening at a psychological level that makes this so important?
那些生活相对与你相似，生活在与你相同背景下的人。理解他们很容易，因为他们面临的一切都和你面临的一样。但现在我们流动性更强，联系更紧密，我们遇到了背景不同、目标不同、优先事项不同的人，事实上他们可能生活在地球的另一端。所以背景大不相同，建立那种核心理解基础要困难得多。你认为为什么被理解对人类如此重要，哈里？在心理层面发生了什么使得这如此重要？
Well, I think that's a very interesting question, Shankar. I think one of the reasons for that is that when you feel understood, it's much easier to connect with another person. It means you don't need to explain yourself repeatedly. It gives you a greater sense of coherence that the world is predictable and sensible, and that you can move in it freely
嗯，我认为这是一个非常有趣的问题，尚卡尔。我认为原因之一是，当你感到被理解时，与另一个人建立联系要容易得多。这意味着你不需要反复解释自己。它给你一种更大的连贯感，即世界是可预测和合理的，你可以自由地在其中移动
without having to worry about how you're coming across. Am I being likable? Am I being smart? Am I being effective in that situation? I'm wondering if part of this also is that if I feel like you like me for who I am, I feel a greater liberty to actually be myself to be authentic. Well, I feel a greater liberty to be authentic, but I also don't need to worry about rejection. We're primed by evolution to be very concerned about being accepted by our group.
而不必担心你给人的印象如何。我讨人喜欢吗？我聪明吗？我在那种情况下有效吗？我想知道这的一部分是否也是，如果我觉得你因为我是谁而喜欢我，我感到更大的自由去真正做我自己，去真实。嗯，我感到更大的自由去真实，但我也无需担心被拒绝。我们被进化所引导，非常关心被我们的群体所接受。
And we all have a very strong need to belong. And if I'm understood, then I don't have to worry about my true self coming out and getting kicked out by the group. Whereas if I feel like the group really doesn't know me, then I'm constantly having to monitor and protect my status. Harry Rees and a number of researchers have tried to understand a paradox. If one thing to be understood is so important to our relationships
我们都有非常强烈的归属感。如果我被理解了，那么我就不必担心我的真实自我显露出来并被群体踢出去。而如果我觉得群体真的不了解我，那么我必须不断地监控和保护我的地位。哈里·里斯和许多研究人员试图理解一个悖论。如果被理解是如此重要，对我们的关系
and our well-being, why do so many of us regularly keep our true selves hidden? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. A desire to be understood, to be seen for who we are, is a powerful driver of successful relationships between parents and children, between romantic partners, and between colleagues. Knowing that is the easy part. Unfortunately, there are barriers that get in the way of actually reaching such understanding. Paradoxically, one major barrier can be our own desire to be understood. After Harry's first marriage ended, he remarried.
和我们的幸福，为什么我们许多人经常把真实的自我隐藏起来？这就是我们回来时要讨论的。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。渴望被理解，被视为真实的自己，是父母与孩子之间、浪漫伴侣之间以及同事之间成功关系的强大驱动力。知道这一点是容易的部分。不幸的是，有一些障碍阻碍了真正达到这种理解。矛盾的是，一个主要的障碍可能是我们自己想要被理解的渴望。哈里的第一次婚姻结束后，他再婚了。
He and his wife, Elina, are both psychologists, and they've been married for more than 30 years. Despite the longevity of their relationship, there are still moments when things can suddenly unravel over a trivial issue, like buying a new couch for that TV room. We have a relatively small TV room, and we had a couch in there that was comfortable for two people to sit on, but not comfortable for two people to sit on, but not comfortable for two people to recline on. And my wife wanted us to get a new couch that would allow us both to
他和他的妻子艾琳娜都是心理学家，他们已经结婚30多年了。尽管他们的关系很长久，但仍然会有一些时刻，事情会因为琐碎的问题突然崩溃，比如为电视室买一张新沙发。我们有一个相对较小的电视室，我们在那里有一张沙发，两个人坐着很舒服，但两个人躺着不舒服，但两个人躺着不舒服，但两个人躺着不舒服。我妻子想让我们买一张新沙发，让我们俩都能
recline comfortably on it, whereas I wanted to keep this couch because it was perfectly comfortable for me. I'm a large person and this is one of the few couches that I've sat on that worked perfectly for me. And so this seems like a very, you know, we both have reasonable positions of course. And so of course what you did was you sat down reasonably and discussed the pros and cons of getting a new couch, right? Well, no, not exactly. You know, there's a truism that psychologists like to talk about is, who are the worst patients for psychotherapy?
舒服地躺在上面，而我想保留这张沙发，因为它对我来说非常舒服。我是一个大块头，这是我坐过的少数几张对我来说非常完美的沙发之一。所以这看起来像是一个非常，你知道，我们都有合理的立场，当然。所以当然你所做的是你坐下来合理地讨论了买新沙发的利弊，对吧？嗯，不，不完全是。你知道，心理学家喜欢谈论的一个真理是，谁是心理治疗中最糟糕的病人？
And the answer is a couple of psychologists. And the reason for that is that each knows exactly what's wrong with the other person, and if the other person would only fix it, everything would be fine. And in a sense, that's how our initial conversations about the couch began. We would discuss what we liked or didn't like about the couch and each of us would complete the other person's sentences because we were absolutely certain that we understood what was going on in the other ones mind. The key part of that that was so unhelpful is the not allowing the perspectives to be talked about, to allow them to come out in a marriage and for that matter in any kind of relationship, to resolve a conflict involves
答案是一对心理学家。原因是每个人都知道对方有什么问题，如果对方能解决它，一切都会好起来。在某种意义上，这就是我们关于沙发的初步对话开始的方式。我们会讨论我们喜欢或不喜欢沙发的地方，我们每个人都会完成对方的句子，因为我们绝对确定我们理解对方脑子里在想什么。其中最无益的关键部分是，不允许讨论观点，在婚姻中，或者在任何一种关系中，要解决冲突涉及
putting aside one's presumptions about what the other person is thinking and feeling, even if those presumptions might be right, and instead really listening to what the other person is saying, and then making it clear that one really is listening. And that became the solution to the couch problem. When we stopped interrupting each other and stopped talking over each other, and very clearly stated what each of us wanted to happen. We actually came to a very good agreement about it,
放下一个人对对方在想什么和感觉什么的推测，即使这些推测可能是对的，而是真正倾听对方在说什么，然后清楚地表明一个人确实在倾听。这就是沙发问题的解决方案。当我们停止打断对方，停止抢话，并非常清楚地说明我们每个人想要发生什么时。我们实际上就此达成了一个非常好的协议，
which was that we searched for a couch that had the length that my wife wanted and that had the support features that I wanted. And it took a little bit of doing, but we found one, and it's coming next week. And of course, this is a trivial example. It obviously resolved in a perfectly happy manner, but you can see how the same dynamics play out in all kinds of other situations with far less agreeable outcomes, where two parties are in conflict
那就是我们寻找了一张既有我妻子想要的长度，又有我想要的支撑功能的沙发。这花了一点功夫，但我们找到了，下周就到了。当然，这是一个琐碎的例子。它显然以一种非常快乐的方式解决了，但你可以看到同样的动态如何在各种其他情况下以远没有那么令人愉快的结果上演，其中双方处于冲突中
with one another. Each of them feels like the other is not, not only not understanding them, but not making any attempt to understand them. Each of them is trying to get that position out, unable to hear what the other person is saying, and this combination of wanting to be understood and not being able to offer understanding to the other person ends up being really toxic. Yes, that's absolutely correct. We are not perfectly articulate human beings. When we communicate, we don't necessarily measure every word perfectly. We use linguistic styles that may not be 100% compatible with the other person.
与对方。他们每个人都觉得对方不仅不理解他们，而且根本没有试图去理解他们。他们每个人都在试图表达那个立场，无法听到对方在说什么，而这种想要被理解却无法向对方提供理解的结合，最终变得非常有毒。是的，那绝对正确。我们不是完美表达的人类。当我们交流时，我们不一定完美地衡量每一个字。我们使用可能与对方不100%兼容的语言风格。
We make assumptions in our heads about what we're thinking and feeling that don't always come across. And so the process of communication is a very imperfect one. And the more imperfect it is, the more difficult it is to develop a true sense of understanding. So, besides some of the conflicts that we've been talking about in the course of interpersonal relationships, you and others have also identified a host of psychological barriers that cause people in some ways to hide themselves from others but also cause them not to see others clearly. And I wanna look at some of these in detail. The research at Tom Gillovich once ran a study where volunteers were videotaped sampling
我们在脑子里对我们在想什么和感觉什么做出假设，这些假设并不总是能传达出来。所以交流的过程是一个非常不完美的过程。它越不完美，发展出真正的理解感就越困难。所以，除了我们一直在谈论的人际关系中的一些冲突之外，你和其他人还确定了许多心理障碍，这些障碍导致人们在某种程度上向他人隐藏自己，但也导致他们不能清楚地看到他人。我想详细看看其中的一些。汤姆·吉洛维奇曾经进行过一项研究，志愿者被录像采样
a variety of beverages. And one of these contain a disgusting, vinegar, brine solution. The volunteers were told to conceal their feelings of disgust, and then ask to guess whether others would notice that they were disgusted. Can you tell me what happened and what bearing this has to our conversation about being understood?
各种饮料。其中一种含有令人作呕的醋盐水溶液。志愿者被告知要掩盖他们的厌恶感，然后被要求猜测其他人是否会注意到他们感到厌恶。你能告诉我发生了什么，以及这对我们关于被理解的对话有什么影响吗？
Well, we often assume that other people can see what we're feeling even when we don't actually express those feelings. So often I might be angry but not do a terribly good job of explaining that and I would assume that everyone knows that I'm angry without necessarily that coming across. And of course that's exactly what happened in the study. The volunteers in fact thought that their feelings of disgust would be obvious to other people but they were not. And Tom Gillovich and his colleagues talked about the illusion of transparency, that we believe that what we feel on the inside is transparent to those on the outside.
嗯，我们经常假设即使我们实际上没有表达这些感受，其他人也能看到我们的感受。所以通常我可能很生气，但没有很好地解释这一点，我会假设每个人都知道我很生气，而不一定传达出来。当然，这正是研究中发生的事情。志愿者实际上认为他们的厌恶感对其他人来说是显而易见的，但事实并非如此。汤姆·吉洛维奇和他的同事谈到了透明度错觉，即我们相信我们在内心感受到的东西对外部的人来说是透明的。
Right. And of course, there are big differences in this. Some of us are better at being transparent than others. But one of the biggest misconceptions people have about marriage, especially before they go into marriage, is that their partner will always know what they're thinking and feeling. And this is a very, very destructive expectation. So sometimes, of course, the problem is not that we believe that we are transparent. Sometimes we're actively trying to hide elements of ourselves from others.
对。当然，在这方面有很大的差异。我们有些人比其他人更擅长透明。但人们对婚姻最大的误解之一，特别是在他们进入婚姻之前，是他们的伴侣总是知道他们在想什么和感觉什么。这是一个非常、非常具有破坏性的期望。所以有时，当然，问题不在于我们相信我们是透明的。有时我们正在积极地试图向他人隐藏我们自己的元素。
When you're just getting to know someone, for example, it doesn't seem like a good time to show all of your cards. Yes, and of course there are many situations in which it's appropriate not to show all your cards, but more importantly, I think there are many situations in which people try not to show all their cards when that is actually problematic. In dating situations, for example, we're clearly putting our best foot forward in the early stages and even much later in the relationship. People often have what we call hidden selves.
例如，当你刚开始认识某人时，这看起来不是展示你所有底牌的好时机。是的，当然有很多情况不展示你所有的底牌是合适的，但更重要的是，我认为有很多情况人们试图不展示他们所有的底牌，而这实际上是有问题的。例如，在约会情况下，我们在早期阶段显然表现出最好的一面，甚至在关系后期也是如此。人们通常有所谓的隐藏自我。
We have aspects of ourselves that we're really quite afraid that other people will find out because it's embarrassing, because it will make us vulnerable, because we fear that it might make our partners second guess their interest in us. So you and others have found that when people experience a sense of being understood, they are drawn closer to those people. In other words, being understood prompts people to feel closer to the people who understand them.
我们有我们自己的一些方面，我们真的很担心其他人会发现，因为这很尴尬，因为它会让我们变得脆弱，因为我们担心它可能会让我们的伴侣重新考虑他们对我们的兴趣。所以你和其他人发现，当人们体验到被理解的感觉时，他们会被吸引到那些人身边。换句话说，被理解促使人们感到与理解他们的人更亲近。
But in tenuous relationships, there's something of a vicious cycle. The more insecure we feel, the more hesitant we become about sharing elements of ourselves that might be judged harshly by others. And of course, the less we share, the less close we feel to others. So it seems to me that some of these dynamics can produce a vicious cycle. Yes, you're talking about the idea of self-fulfilling prophecy and the irony there is that in the very situation you described, people will often be right there partner for not understanding them, and yet they've been deliberately hiding aspects of themselves. hiding aspects of themselves. So we've looked at several ways in which we might hide important parts of ourselves from others, but let's flip the script for a second. It turns out that we also regularly fail to take the time to extend understanding to others. And to go back to your story about the couch, part of the problem was that you were not slowing down enough to hear your wife's perspective because you were so anxious to get out your
但在脆弱的关系中，存在一种恶性循环。我们感到越不安全，我们就越犹豫是否要分享可能被他人严厉评判的我们自己的元素。当然，我们分享得越少，我们感到与他人越不亲近。所以在我看来，其中一些动态会产生恶性循环。是的，你谈论的是自我实现预言的想法，其中的讽刺之处在于，在你描述的情况中，人们经常会因为他们的伴侣不理解他们而责怪他们，然而他们却一直在故意隐藏自己的方面。隐藏自己的方面。所以我们看了几种我们可能向他人隐藏我们自己重要部分的方式，但让我们暂时翻转一下剧本。事实证明，我们也经常没有花时间去向他人延伸理解。回到你关于沙发的故事，问题的一部分是你没有放慢速度去听你妻子的观点，因为你太急于表达你
own. Yes. Well, many times we are much more interested in expressing our point of view than in listening to the other person's point of view. This is one of the great conversation skills that people sometimes need to learn. Instead of listening, people will be thinking about what's the next thing I'm going to say. And when you do that, it's that much harder to understand what the other person is actually talking about. We really have to learn how to focus our attention on the
自己的。是的。嗯，很多时候我们对表达我们的观点比倾听对方的观点更感兴趣。这是人们有时需要学习的伟大对话技巧之一。人们不是在倾听，而是在思考我接下来要说的话。当你这样做时，理解对方真正在谈论什么就困难得多了。我们真的必须学习如何将我们的注意力集中在
other person rather than ourselves. I'm wondering if gender dynamics play a role here as well. It seems to me at least from anecdotal experience that women are more forthcoming than men are in sort of revealing elements of themselves and wanting to be understood and seeking to understand, is that a stereotype? What do you think there's some truth in it? Well, what there is truth in, I think, is the idea that women are better at doing the understanding.
对方身上，而不是我们自己身上。我想知道性别动态在这里是否也起作用。至少从轶事经验来看，女性比男性更坦率，在某种程度上揭示自己的元素，想要被理解，并寻求理解，这是一个刻板印象吗？你认为其中有一些真理吗？嗯，我认为有真理的是，女性更擅长做理解这件事。
Women are better at paying attention to what other person's saying and expressing that in a way that comes across to the other person. Women also do tend to be somewhat more emotionally open. We've done a lot of research on that gender difference, and what's interesting about it is that women tend to be relatively more open regardless of the gender of the person that they're talking to. But men tend to be open primarily with women. In other words, men when they're interacting with other men are
女性更擅长注意对方在说什么，并以一种对方能理解的方式表达出来。女性也倾向于在情感上更开放。我们对此性别差异做了很多研究，有趣的是，女性倾向于相对更开放，无论她们正在交谈的人的性别如何。但男性倾向于主要与女性开放。换句话说，男性在与其他男性互动时
less likely to be emotionally open. And that often interferes with men's developing close friendships, particularly later in life. You have an interesting story about something you overheard at the gym, where a couple of men were having a heart to heart, or at least one of them was having a heart to heart. Yes, I was at my gym, and there were two young men standing there, and one of them said, you know, how are you doing to the other? And the other said, oh, it's just terrible. My wife left me, I lost my job, and I had an auto accident. The other man said, wow, you know, it's really important to get your feelings out.
不太可能在情感上开放。这通常会干扰男性发展亲密的友谊，特别是在以后的生活中。你有一个关于你在健身房无意中听到的事情的有趣故事，两个男人正在进行交心，或者至少其中一个正在进行交心。是的，我在我的健身房，有两个年轻人站在那里，其中一个说，你知道，你怎么样对另一个说。另一个说，哦，太糟糕了。我妻子离开了我，我丢了工作，我还出了车祸。另一个人说，哇，你知道，把你的感受表达出来真的很重要。
Why don't you tell me about it? My ears perked up. I thought, wow, this is exactly what we're talking about. Then he said, and I've got a minute, so go ahead. Ha, ha, ha. I feel there are also times, Harry, when we may actively not want to understand someone else. So if you sense that a friend or a colleague
你为什么不告诉我呢？我的耳朵竖起来了。我想，哇，这正是我们正在谈论的。然后他说，我有一分钟时间，所以继续吧。哈哈哈哈。我觉得也有时候，哈里，当我们可能主动不想理解别人时。所以如果你感觉到一个朋友或同事
or a romantic partner thinks poorly of you, it almost might be less painful if you engaged in some willful blindness. Can you talk about this as being one of the barriers to actually understanding other people? Yes, we talk about this as when the head protects the heart. And the simple idea here is that there are many things that other people might be thinking about us that we don't want to know about.
或浪漫伴侣对你评价不高，如果你进行一些故意失明，这可能几乎不那么痛苦。你能谈谈这是理解他人的障碍之一吗？是的，我们谈论这个是当头脑保护心脏时。这里简单的想法是，其他人可能对我们有很多想法，我们不想知道。
For example, early in a dating relationship, we may not want to really know what the other person thinks of ourselves. It might be unpleasant. It might not be what we want to hear. In a conversation with a teacher or a work supervisor, we may not want to really know what the other person thinks of what we're doing because it may not be entirely complementary to ourselves. And so, often we have blinders. Now, of course, when you take this to an extreme, it's quite dysfunctional.
例如，在约会关系的早期，我们可能不想真正知道对方对我们有什么看法。这可能是不愉快的。这可能不是我们想听到的。在与老师或工作主管的对话中，我们可能不想真正知道对方对我们正在做的事情有什么看法，因为它可能并不完全是对我们自己的补充。所以，我们经常有眼罩。当然，当你把这个推向极端时，它是相当功能失调的。
But at relatively low levels, this may be highly functional. We often do a getting acquainted exercise with students where we ask students what superpower they would like. And as soon as a later one student always says the ability to read other people's minds, and I think it's safe to say that the ability to read other people's mind is the worst thing that could happen to us. Research has once asked a couple of hundred couples to write down every evening for a couple of weeks how considered or selfish that partner had been
但在相对较低的水平上，这可能是高度功能的。我们经常和学生做一个结识练习，我们问学生他们想要什么超能力。一旦后来一个学生总是说读懂别人心思的能力，我认为可以肯定地说，读懂别人心思的能力是我们可能发生的最糟糕的事情。研究曾经要求几百对夫妇在几周内每天晚上写下他们的伴侣有多体贴或自私
or how supportive that'd been. And then I've had them predict how that partners would behave the next day. And the researchers generally found that people believed that the way that partners had behaved on day one was a good predictor of how they would behave on day two. So in other words, we assume that the people who we're engaging with today, their behaviors are not
或者有多支持。然后我让他们预测那些伴侣第二天会表现如何。研究人员通常发现，人们认为伴侣在第一天的表现是他们第二天表现的良好预测指标。所以换句话说，我们假设我们今天正在与之互动的人，他们的行为不是
going to change in the future. And of course, one of the reasons in some ways we fail to understand other people is that our impressions of who they are are rooted in the past. Well, we have a strong belief that character is a major determinant of behavior. And so we assume that people are going to be consistent from one situation to another, from one day to another, indeed, even from one period of life to another period of life. And what we under consider is the idea that people grow, people change, that people's situations change, and that that
未来会发生改变。当然，我们在某些方面无法理解他人的原因之一，就是我们对他们的印象根植于过去。我们坚定地认为性格是决定行为的主要因素。因此，我们假设人们在不同情境下、不同日子里，甚至在人生的不同阶段，行为都是一致的。但我们忽略了人们会成长、会改变，人们所处的环境也会改变，而这些
leads them to behave in different ways as well. So often when we're dealing with partners, when we're dealing with students, when we're dealing with co-workers, we don't account for the fact that people develop, people change in priorities, people mature, and they behave differently over time. This is especially, I think, acute when you're talking about parents and children, so the mom who thinks the adolescent son always needs help has trouble adapting to the fact that maybe the adolescent son now is 25 years old and perhaps doesn't need her help as much.
也会导致他们表现出不同的行为。所以，当我们与伴侣、学生或同事打交道时，往往忽略了人们会发展、优先事项会改变、会成熟，并且随着时间的推移，他们的行为也会有所不同。我认为，当谈到父母和孩子时，这一点尤为明显。比如，一位母亲认为她十几岁的儿子总是需要帮助，却难以适应这样一个事实：也许她十几岁的儿子现在已经25岁了，可能不再那么需要她的帮助了。
One of the hardest things about parenting is that children develop and they often develop rather quickly and recognizing the skill changes or the need changes that a child goes through is often difficult for parents to keep up with. Tell me about the time your mom came to visit you when you were first in Rochester. You were 25 years old, I believe. Tell me that story, Harry. Yes, I was 25 years old. This was the first time I lived in a house of my own.
为人父母最困难的事情之一就是孩子会成长，而且往往成长得很快。父母往往很难跟上孩子在技能或需求方面的变化。跟我讲讲你刚到罗切斯特时你妈妈来看你的那次经历吧。我相信你当时25岁。讲讲那个故事，哈里。是的，我当时25岁。那是我第一次住进自己的房子。
My mother walked in the door and without taking her jacket off, started to clean the sink. And it was not that dirty. Did you have a conversation with her about this? I mean, you say, you know, I'm the psychologist. I know exactly what you're doing. No, I was happy to have my sink clean. One of the things I'm taking away from all this work, Harry, is that, you know, being understood requires significant effort from two parties. Understanding tends to happen when you have an excellent communicator paired with an excellent empath. Of course, when you put it that way, it becomes much less surprising that so many of us go
我母亲走进门，外套都没脱，就开始清理水槽。其实水槽并不脏。你和她谈过这件事吗？我的意思是，你说，你知道，我是心理学家。我完全知道你在做什么。不，我很高兴我的水槽被清理干净了。哈里，我从所有这些研究中得出的结论之一是，被理解需要双方付出巨大的努力。当一位优秀的沟通者与一位优秀的共情者相遇时，理解往往就会发生。当然，当你这样说的时候，很多人没有
through life without getting the understanding that we want or without extending understanding to others. Yes, that's correct. A failure on either end of that transaction can make it go bad. Can you talk for a moment about the experience of getting this understanding, given that it's rare, given that it doesn't happen always, I think many of us have a feeling of almost transcendence when we feel like we're paired with someone who truly gets us. Well, I would not quite want to go as far as you're going
得到他们想要的理解，或者没有向他人表达理解，也就不足为奇了。是的，没错。交易中任何一方的失败都可能导致结果不尽如人意。你能谈谈获得这种理解的体验吗？考虑到这很罕见，考虑到它并不总是发生，我想我们许多人在感到与真正懂我们的人相遇时，几乎有一种超越感。嗯，我不想走得像你那么远，
and saying that we don't have this kind of understanding. We certainly don't have this kind of complete understanding. But if we didn't have some level of understanding, we would all be deflecting and bouncing off each other in many ways. So there's some level of basic understanding that is quite common in our lives. And for that to happen, we have to be reasonably open in expressing what's important to us
说我们没有这种理解。我们当然没有这种完全的理解。但如果我们没有某种程度的理解，我们所有人都会在很多方面互相排斥和碰撞。所以，我们生活中确实存在某种程度的基本理解。为了实现这一点，我们必须相当坦诚地表达对我们重要的事情，
and reasonably good listeners in paying attention to what's being said to us. When we come back, a curious twist. It turns out there is a big difference between being understood and feeling understood. Also, given the barriers we face to understanding, what skills can help us become more connected to others and allow us to understand them a little better. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. The desire to feel understood appears to be a core psychological need. When we have it, we are happier colleagues, warmer partners, and more loyal friends. When we don't feel understood, it can corrode even our best relationships. Psychologist Harry Reece studies intimate relationships.
并且作为倾听者，要相当善于关注对方所说的话。回来后，我们将探讨一个有趣的转折。事实证明，被理解和感觉被理解之间存在巨大差异。此外，面对理解的障碍，哪些技能可以帮助我们与他人建立更紧密的联系，并让我们更好地理解他们？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。渴望被理解似乎是一种核心的心理需求。当我们拥有它时，我们是更快乐的同事、更温暖的伴侣和更忠诚的朋友。当我们感觉不被理解时，它甚至会腐蚀我们最好的关系。心理学家哈里·里斯研究亲密关系。
He's found that being understood is a pillar of successful relationships, but there are all kinds of cognitive biases that keep us from being understood and keep us from understanding others. Harry, one of the most interesting aspects of your research is that you found a difference between being understood and feeling understood. Can you explain this difference to me? Yes.
他发现被理解是成功关系的支柱，但各种认知偏差阻碍了我们被理解，也阻碍了我们理解他人。哈里，你研究中最有趣的方面之一是你发现了被理解和感觉被理解之间的区别。你能向我解释一下这个区别吗？是的。
Being understood refers to whether you really understand what another person is like, what their preferences are, what their character traits are, what their needs are, what their desires are, feeling understood. It's entirely within the mind of the perceiver and it's the belief that another person really understands who you are and what's important to you. And you're saying that there are sometimes cases where people may feel understood without actually being understood? Yes, there are. One of the things we've found in our work
被理解是指你是否真正了解另一个人的样子、他们的偏好、性格特征、需求和欲望。而感觉被理解，完全存在于感知者的心中，是一种认为对方真正了解你是谁以及什么对你重要的信念。你是说有时人们会感觉被理解，但实际上并没有被理解？是的，确实如此。我们在工作中发现的一件事
is that when people have a successful relationships, they often imagine that other people understand them better than they actually do. And this is one thing that actually helps them maintain a sense of security and safety in that relationship. And you've done studies to this effect, I understand, where you show that in some ways the belief that you are understood, the feeling that you have
是，当人们拥有成功的关系时，他们往往会想象对方比实际情况更了解自己。这实际上有助于他们在关系中保持一种安全感。我了解到你做过相关的研究，证明在某种程度上，你被理解的信念，即你所拥有的
of being understood, in fact, is a strong predictor of the success of that relationship, not necessarily the fact that people actually are understood. Correct. Well, what we did in this work was look at the extent to which people felt understood by their close relationship partners in two different areas. One is in the area of sexual preferences
被理解的感觉，实际上是关系成功的有力预测指标，而不一定是人们实际上被理解的事实。没错。嗯，我们在这项工作中做的是观察人们在两个不同领域中被亲密关系伴侣理解的程度。一个是性偏好领域，
and the other was in the area of humor preferences. And what we found was quite interesting and that's that when people feel very satisfied with their relationships and when they feel very similar to the people that they're relating to, they actually imagine that there's a greater level of understanding than there actually is. Now this is a good thing because that greater level of feeling understood allows them to feel more confident, more safe, more happy in the relationship. So we talk about this as a maintenance mechanism and by that we mean a way of thinking about your relationship
另一个是幽默偏好领域。我们发现了一个非常有趣的现象，那就是当人们对关系感到非常满意，并且觉得与他们交往的人非常相似时，他们实际上会想象出比实际情况更高水平的理解。这其实是一件好事，因为这种更高水平的被理解感让他们在关系中感到更自信、更安全、更快乐。所以我们称之为维护机制，我们的意思是这是一种看待你关系的方式，
that actually boosts the integrity and the coherence and the safety of the relationship. I'm thinking about this also in the context of politics. Politicians like Bill Clinton or Donald Trump, they're loved by their supporters in part because people feel like they understand them. Is that stretching your research too far to extend it to the realm of politics? No, I think that implication follows quite naturally. Both Bill Clinton and Donald Trump were able to communicate to other people something that made it sound like he really understood what was important to those people.
它实际上增强了关系的完整性、连贯性和安全性。我也在政治背景下思考这个问题。像比尔·克林顿或唐纳德·特朗普这样的政治家，他们受到支持者的喜爱，部分原因是因为人们觉得他们理解他们。将你的研究扩展到政治领域是否太牵强了？不，我认为这种推论非常自然。比尔·克林顿和唐纳德·特朗普都能够向他人传达某种信息，使人觉得他真的理解对那些人来说什么才是重要的。
And that is a major determinant of people's identification with candidates. They're willingness to go out and vote for those candidates or perhaps to even donate to them. In my state, when people lose their jobs, there's a good chance I'll know them by their names. When a factory closes, I know the people who ran it. When the businesses go bankrupt, I know them. People that have lost their jobs, lost their livelihood, lost their health insurance. What I want you to understand is on the campaign, I called it the forgotten man and the forgotten woman. Well, you're not forgotten anymore that I can tell you. Not forgotten anymore.
这是人们认同候选人的主要决定因素。他们愿意出去为这些候选人投票，甚至可能为他们捐款。在我的州，当人们失业时，我很有可能叫得出他们的名字。当工厂倒闭时，我认识经营它的人。当企业破产时，我认识他们。那些失去工作、失去生计、失去医疗保险的人。我想让你们明白的是，在竞选活动中，我称他们为被遗忘的男人和被遗忘的女人。好吧，我可以告诉你们，你们不再被遗忘了。不再被遗忘了。
And I think it might also be a measure of how much we are willing to forgive candidates, even if they fail to deliver on promises that they have made to us. When we feel like the candidates understand us, that this leader truly gets us, this leader is perhaps even one of us. You're willing to forgive all kinds of things, even if the candidate doesn't actually deliver once he or she is in office. Yes, I think that's exactly right. I want to turn to some of the techniques that we can use to better understand other people and to be better understood by others. Psychotherapists sometimes use a technique called speaker listener technique to help couples
我认为这可能也是衡量我们愿意原谅候选人程度的一个指标，即使他们未能兑现对我们做出的承诺。当我们觉得候选人理解我们，觉得这位领导者真正懂我们，这位领导者甚至可能是我们中的一员时，你愿意原谅各种事情，即使候选人在上任后并没有真正兑现承诺。是的，我认为完全正确。我想转向一些我们可以用来更好地理解他人以及被他人更好地理解的技巧。心理治疗师有时会使用一种称为“说话者-倾听者”的技术来帮助夫妻
overcome misunderstandings. Can you describe this technique to me, Harry? Sure. The speaker listener technique is a very straightforward way of trying to both enforce the idea of needing to listen, but also to create the sense of being listened to. So in the speaker-listener technique, there will be a box on the table with two red lights, one in front of each partner.
克服误解。你能为我描述一下这种技术吗，哈里？当然。说话者-倾听者技术是一种非常直接的方法，既能强化需要倾听的理念，也能创造一种被倾听的感觉。所以，在说话者-倾听者技术中，桌子上会有一个盒子，上面有两个红灯，每个伴侣面前各一个。
And the way the process works is only the partner who has the light is allowed to speak. So the lights on, you're allowed to speak, and you can say whatever your concerns or issues are, then the light switches, and the partner's job is to repeat what you just said as they heard it. Then the first person's light comes back on, and that person then has to comment on whether you got it right or how you got it wrong.
这个过程的运作方式是，只有拥有灯光的伴侣才被允许说话。所以灯亮着，你就可以说话，你可以说出你的任何担忧或问题，然后灯光切换，伴侣的工作是重复你刚才所说的话，正如他们所听到的那样。然后第一个人的灯重新亮起，那个人必须评论你是否理解正确，或者你在哪里理解错了。
And then the other person's light comes back on and they have to amend what they said to reflect the feedback that you just gave them. So in some ways you're slowing people down to the point where each side says, not only have I had my say, I am now sure the other person has heard me in exactly the way that I wanna be heard. Right, but it's more than just slowing down because lots of times people know that they have to shut up
然后另一个人的灯重新亮起，他们必须修改他们所说的话，以反映你刚才给他们的反馈。所以，在某种程度上，你是在放慢人们的节奏，直到双方都说：不仅我表达了我的观点，而且我现在确信对方已经以我想要被听到的方式听到了我的话。没错，但这不仅仅是放慢速度，因为很多时候人们知道他们必须闭嘴，
while the other person is saying the point of view, but their mind will be closed. This technique forces them to open their minds and really listen to what's being said. Uh-huh. What are the salutary effects that greater understanding might bring, both in terms of our personal psychology, but also in the way we treat other people? Yes, we've done a number of studies of this where we use an experimental manipulation that will temporarily allow people to feel more understood or alternatively to feel more misunderstood.
当对方在陈述观点时，但他们的思想会是封闭的。这种技术迫使他们敞开心扉，真正倾听所说的话。嗯哼。更大的理解会带来哪些有益的影响，无论是在我们的个人心理方面，还是在我们对待他人的方式上？是的，我们对此做过许多研究，我们使用了一种实验操纵，可以暂时让人们感到更被理解，或者相反，感到更被误解。
And what we find is that once we give people a sense that they've been understood, that they've been validated and responded to, they become more open-minded, they become more willing to consider opposite points of view. This is work that I did with an Israeli colleague named Guy Itchakoff and we gave people a sense of being understood and Then measured their prejudice toward some out group that they might have known Perhaps it was an ethnic group perhaps it was people with a different sexuality. Some group that prior to the study they had expressed some negativity toward. And we found that after feeling understood they become less concerned with inflating their view of themselves, of thinking of themselves in a more ego-enhancing way. And most importantly and most interestingly, they become less
我们发现，一旦我们让人们感觉到他们被理解了，他们被认可并得到了回应，他们就会变得更加开明，更愿意考虑相反的观点。这是我和一位名叫盖伊·伊查科夫的以色列同事共同完成的工作，我们让人们产生一种被理解的感觉，然后测量他们对某些他们可能知道的外群体的偏见。也许是一个族群，也许是不同性取向的人。在研究之前，他们对这些群体表达过一些负面情绪。我们发现，在感到被理解后，他们不再那么关心夸大对自己的看法，不再那么以自我提升的方式思考自己。最重要、最有趣的是，他们变得不那么
prejudiced towards out groups. I'm wondering if you can tell me a little bit about some of the techniques that you employ yourself, having done this work for many years after seeing the importance of actual understanding as well as communicating understanding to other people. How has this changed the way you interact with others in terms of your students, your colleagues, your partners, your friends, your family? Do you do things differently today than you did in the past? Oh, absolutely. One of the things I do particularly with students is that, you know, students will often come to you with a request for this that or the other thing. And often it's not a request that we can grant. And rather than just, you know, say, no, sorry, I will sort of go out
对外部群体有偏见了。我想知道你是否能告诉我一些你自己采用的技巧，在做了多年这项工作并看到实际理解以及向他人传达理解的重要性之后。这如何改变了你与他人互动的方式，包括你的学生、同事、伴侣、朋友和家人？你今天做的事情和过去有什么不同吗？哦，绝对有。我特别对学生做的一件事是，你知道，学生经常会带着这样或那样的请求来找你。通常这不是我们能满足的请求。与其只是说，不，抱歉，我会尽量
of my way to make it clear that I understood what they said. I think it's a perfectly reasonable thing for them to ask for. But I just can't do it. They may feel turned down, but at least they know that I paid attention and respected where they were coming from. I want to stay with that insight for a moment, because in some ways I think what you're hinting at at least is that sometimes the pain we feel in disagreements might be less about the disagreement, and it might be more about how we feel the other person has heard us or listened to us or taken us seriously. Absolutely. There is research by one of my colleagues, Amy Gordon, where she has shown that conflicts, even when they don't get resolved,
明确表示我理解他们所说的话。我认为他们提出这个要求是完全合理的。但我就是做不到。他们可能会感到被拒绝，但至少他们知道我关注了他们，并尊重他们的立场。我想在这个见解上停留片刻，因为在某种程度上，我认为你至少是在暗示，有时我们在分歧中感受到的痛苦可能与分歧本身无关，而更多地与我们觉得对方是否听取了我们、倾听了我们或认真对待了我们有关。绝对是这样。我的同事艾米·戈登的研究表明，冲突即使没有得到解决，
are less harmful to relationships when people feel like they've been heard and understood. One of the misconceptions that people have is that if you express understanding for what the other person is saying that you're somehow agreeing with their point of view, and that needn't be the case. Understanding simply means making it clear that you get the message that they communicated and that you respect it as a reasonable point of view. That doesn't mean that you have to agree with it. But it's what flagging. The reason that I think many of us fail to do this,
当人们觉得他们被倾听和理解时，对关系的伤害也会减少。人们的一个误解是，如果你表达对对方所说内容的理解，你就是在某种程度上同意他们的观点，而事实并非如此。理解仅仅意味着明确表示你收到了他们传达的信息，并且你尊重它作为一个合理的观点。这并不意味着你必须同意它。但值得指出的是。我认为我们许多人无法做到这一点，
fail to understand others or fail to have ourselves be understood. Is it actually, is it's hard? It does involve time, it involves effort, and it involves emotional effort. And it also involves vulnerability. It involves being open to hearing something that you might not like. So in some ways, the act of doing this involves you know an element of courage I suppose. It definitely involves courage. The courage to tell you who I really am and the courage to listen to who you really are. Harry Rees is a psychologist at the University of Rochester. Harry, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain.
无法理解他人或无法让自己被理解的原因是，这实际上很难。它确实需要时间，需要努力，也需要情感上的努力。它还涉及脆弱性。它涉及愿意听到你可能不喜欢的东西。所以，在某种程度上，做这件事的行为涉及一种勇气，我想。它绝对涉及勇气。向你展示我真实自我的勇气，以及倾听你真实自我的勇气。哈里·里斯是罗切斯特大学的心理学家。哈里，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》节目。
My pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Bands, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is the psychologist Sonia Lubamirski.
我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·科雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·班兹和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是心理学家索尼娅·柳博米尔斯基。
She was featured on our recent episode Where Happiness Hides. After we talked, Sonia told us about Harry Reese's research on the importance of feeling understood. Thank you Sonia for introducing us to Harry. We are working on a story about personality. Have you ever tried to change who you are in a fundamental way? We are looking for stories of people who have attempted to transform themselves in some important fashion.
她曾出现在我们最近的一期节目《幸福隐藏在哪里》中。谈话结束后，索尼娅告诉我们哈里·里斯关于被理解重要性的研究。谢谢索尼娅把哈里介绍给我们。我们正在制作一个关于人格的故事。你是否曾经尝试过从根本上改变自己？我们正在寻找那些试图以某种重要方式改变自己的人的故事。
Perhaps this change was the result of an unexpected encounter or an epiphany, but the person you were afterwards was different than the one you were before. We're especially interested in stories of personal growth. If the strikes occurred and you're willing to share your story of your moment of epiphany and your transformation with the Hidden Brain audience. Please find a quiet room and record a short voice memo on your phone.
也许这种改变是一次意外邂逅或顿悟的结果，但之后的你与之前的你不同。我们对个人成长的故事特别感兴趣。如果这些触动发生了，并且你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的顿悟时刻和转变故事。请找一个安静的房间，在手机上录制一段简短的语音备忘录。
Email it to us at ideasathydenbrain.org. Again, that's ideasathydenbrain.org. Use the subject line, Transformation. If you like Hidden Brain, please check out our store at shop.hiddenbrain.org. We have t-shirts, hoodies, mugs and more. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次强调，是ideas@hiddenbrain.org。使用主题行：Transformation。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请查看我们的商店 shop.hiddenbrain.org。我们有T恤、连帽衫、马克杯等。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。